[Music]
how's it going everyone my name is nari
sol i'm a pianist composer my roots are
in classical music but i enjoy exploring
other genres and writing my own music
and in general i love adding my own
twist to things which is what we'll be
doing today to a bach invention
going to take the one in d minor and i'm
going to create my own version of it
based on some of the harmonic rhythmic
and linear elements of the piece
here are some of the details of this
invention that i took notes on first of
all it's in d minor
here's the main motive which you'll hear
repeated in different forms
and like other bach inventions there are
two independent voices that create the
moving harmonies together
also i'm noticing the ongoing 16th notes
that create momentum and the more
punctual eighth notes that provide a bit
more spine to the piece
[Music]
what i'm going for with the piece is
something light-hearted
buoyant airy whimsical
almost like a fairy tale or something in
a storybook so now with these points in
mind i began elaborating on the basic
structures of the piece to come up with
this piano part
i found that as i was adding more notes
the general feel of the piece was
becoming lighter instead of the opposite
i think it's because each note had
lesser weight than before in the
original i was also trying to add these
notes that sort of curl upwards for a
more buoyant quality
[Music]
and by adding more layers and cords in
general especially these jazz influence
seventh chords i think the piece has a
warmer quality to it in general
now let's move on to the creation of my
virtual ensemble which will serve as my
backing track i'm choosing to go a few
extra steps beyond recording just piano
because i'm inspired quite a bit by
technology recently specifically using
sample libraries and virtual instruments
that sort of thing for the last few
months i've been learning more about
midi programming
using cubase and just learning more
about production in general and
this has seeped into many areas of my
work
and it sparked new ideas because i
essentially have more things in my
toolbox and this is one of them
[Music]
[Applause]
usually i'll just stop at a piano
version but this time i programmed
something that i'll be using as
a virtual
accompaniment i guess as i'm recording
the piano part
oh yeah i do
all right so here are my tracks that
i've been working with so far some are
recorded directly from the keyboard and
some are using virtual instruments so
here first organ
and i also added harpsichord
[Music]
and then this spell-like synth
[Music]
yeah why not and then two roads
very friendly
and then the stuff high on top two
glockenspiels and one piano
[Music]
and then of course the strings which i'm
having difficulty programming i'm
actually using two different libraries
and
this is just sort of a hack solution
uh but
maybe it'll work i'm not sure
[Applause]
we will see
we will see and then just a little
horn
and low synth
so while i was programming this i
actually had this piano playing
[Music]
which i will mute when i record the real
piano
so that is more or less how everything
sounds let me just play it all together
[Music]
so that's the gist of it i think the
high pitched sounds like the
glockenspiel high piano and the strings
of course really add to this
fairytale storybook like quality
so i'm going to be able to record the
piano part at the village studios in the
moroccan room thank you so much jeff for
allowing me to use the space i'm super
excited because this is not only an
iconic location
it's just a studio filled with such
great history and i know the piano there
is amazing the sound of the space is
really really great and i know that by
recording the piano part this piece will
really come to life rather than having
everything programmed yeah i believe uh
the eric clapton's tears in heaven was
recorded here
oscar peterson yeah oh what
just a quick additional note on how this
idea came about i am partially
influenced by composers out there from
the past and present that have taken box
works and created their own versions of
it or
transcriptions that sort of thing or any
work for that matter
many composers have dialogues with each
other and
this is a common thing i think
especially with
older traditional music and i really
love that
also on top of that it's just fun to
take
a piece of music that you already know
and
just make it original by adding your own
twist to it and
taking these lines to different places
and trying things out
what i tell myself why not just let's
just try it
so that was behind how this started and
we're just gonna see
where it goes
yeah let's do it
good thing the piece is short otherwise
i'm going to start off by playing box
original invention in d minor
[Music]
and now my final version of the piece
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
do you have any thoughts
um sound really good
awesome you're very patient
you
overall i really enjoyed this experience
i liked how i started off with one thing
that i really didn't envision would turn
into the final piece so i just took it
one step at a time
if i were to do this again i might
record the piano part first and then
program around it because i think
although it's fun to play with the
backing track it was pretty difficult to
fit everything into what was
pre-programmed other than that
i really enjoyed it i especially loved
recording at the village
thank you so much again and thank you
all for watching i will see you in the
next video also thank you so much to all
of my patrons on patreon for your
continued support i really really
appreciate it i hope you all enjoy this
and see you all soon
by the way if you enjoyed this you may
also want to check out some other videos
that i've done involving box music such
as my how to sound like bock video the
genius behind box goldberg variations
canons video or my making new music with
old music video among several others